Apple Microsoft and alphabet which is
Google and YouTube they all come to the
same political persuasion and they all
have the ability to pinch the valve and
close that shut off the tap of
information hello there Happy
Thanksgiving if you think that's racist
this isn't the video for you quick
warning you may hear some squeaking
hopper and Betty are playing with some
toys around so I apologize this is a
little bit raw doll mostly be me talking
and a screen recording from my iPhone
that's a little reminiscent of the Alexa
video that I think we did on
Thanksgiving Yeah right before Black
Friday two years ago and I noticed
something with my iPhone that was
equally disconcerting so before we get
to that question of the day you know
it's very easy to see inherent biases on
YouTube or Alexa Google right we sort of
think of these as platforms software but
sometimes a little bit harder to pick up
if it's baked into the entire ecosystem
of your smartphone a lot of you love
iphones that's what i'm working with
today but i'm sure it happens on android
too and i know their software there's a
bunch of stuff going on here but for the
purpose of this video i'm just referring
to it as smartphone hopper come here
buddy come here that's okay hoppers just
walking around I apologize so my
question to you is have you seen this
with your device how egregious has it
gotten and I would like for you to
conduct some of these experiments that
I'm about to show you and comment below
or send me your tweets a Tess Crowder
and show me your results because I am
concerned so we'll start off with a
couple of things right right off the bat
I don't know if you've seen these but
the new gender-neutral emojis the
families this isn't a big deal so I'm
gonna try and do this in sort of
ascending order of and hopper there's
nothing you see even he doesn't like the
iPhone he's not a big fan of it
apparently apparently he's an Android
guy but I'm gonna send these to my wife
because she's the only one who I can
send these emojis to do you have two
dads and two moms as opposed to a
traditional family they change these
apps these emojis proactively which
wouldn't seem like it matters until you
realize that they change some emojis
because people felt that they were
racially insensitive you know I thought
that they were - white people weren't
represented equally enough so activists
have determined that emojis are a
political stand that they want to make
by its own may not
like a big deal but Apple knows that all
of your kids are using smartphones and
that brings us though to something you
know apps and I think a lot of you know
that there are some biases with apps
right there's been a lot of conservative
apps that have been banned on the App
Store
on the iPhone I said like no person on
the App Store on the iPhone that's the
one with email correct but so that's
nothing new like in the totality of this
when you add it up and we get to Apple
News I think you'll agree it's pretty
disturbing apps that have been banned
obviously Infowars you have a lot of
Christian apps have been banned from the
App Store pro-life organizations human
Coalition Exodus is one of them and
something else so you see well okay
maybe they just disagree with them
because they have some kind of religious
content fine they also have some apps
have been banned gab which is a free
speech platform right there's trying to
compete with other social media
platforms that's banned as well as
applications that were used by the Hong
Kong protesters so I don't really know
how you can justify that especially for
talking about a more open and free
society in supporting the downtrodden
right the underdog how do you ban apps
that were being used to mobilize freedom
activists protesters in Hong Kong so all
of those have been banned from the App
Store but and let me just do this right
now I'll do this with a screen capture
if I search Planned Parenthood however
look at that right there I have a screen
grab but just so you can see there's
there's nothing up my sleeve I must have
picked the wrong hat Planned Parenthood
shows up Chinese protesters will Hong
Kong protesters and I'm gonna get flak
for that nothing and that brings me to
the next point the podcasts right the
app for podcasts we all know that you
know Infowars alex jones was banned from
podcasts but here's the thing he was
banned for hate speech for violating
hate speech guidelines it wasn't for
conspiratorial content didn't have
anything to do with Sandy Hook and I by
the way i disagree with alex jones in a
whole lot and i understand that you may
but the reason he was removed was for
hate speech let's contrast that with pro
violent anti-fur activists podcasts like
is it's uh what's this one Johnny boy
it's going that's right it's going
there's another one that's something
like a chapel house chapel I don't know
they endorse an to the violence by the
way that's that's that's all I know
there we go
oh if we search it's going down on the
podcast app and lest you think I
exaggerate you can search that yourself
and see the endorsement of ant for
violence brutally beating in people's
heads it's fun for the whole family
Happy Thanksgiving
and finally that brings me here to what
I think is most concerning is Apple news
especially when you see that so many
more Americans are getting their news
aggregated from Apple news and they have
more and more control over the flow of
information now I want to be really
clear about something before you say
well that's just an algorithm it's based
on your favorites I do use Apple news
every day I know you think I have to
change political affiliation it's one of
the tools that I use okay I also read
HuffPo and so on every day because I do
it so you don't have to that being said
what we did here on a new phone it was a
new phone completes a completely clean
slate no subscriptions no searches we
didn't favor it we didn't share any
article so all we did was set up Apple
News as a blank slate on a new phone and
I want to show you what it is that
popped up far and away far away during
this entire time for three weeks we
monitored it was the Trump impeachment
story all coming up from left-wing news
sources so let me bring this up right
here I had to kind of screen grab them
as they came in impeachment reaches
decision stages Democrats review
evidence there we go that's the very
first thing that pops up and I would get
these notifications all the time it
would just pop up and it almost thought
there were repeat titles State
Department files show Giuliani Pompeo
contact before Ukraine's ambassador
visit next when your Democrats have
wrapped their publication impeachment
what comes next
who the impeachment surprises boost dem
this comes from political but Republican
resistance holds all right next story
top news five key things we learn from
Gordon Sunland very nice next top
stories these are all popping up on my
phone by this is what's so disturbing
this is pumped to your phone or you get
a notification hey here's a news alert
and then if you swipe right you just
have this control panel I guess is what
it's called that just has a list of top
stories for three weeks they were all
impeachment they were all Trump
impeachment Ukraine or Russia scandal
which by the way pick a lane is a
Trumper is at Ukraine they don't really
like
each other next when impeachment witness
Ukraine gradually came to understand
that they were being asked to do don't
address the title another one
impeachment probe turns to Trump a lie
at the heart of the Ukraine another one
witness says the over Trump demand
Ukrainian vestigation of Biden's another
one trump ousted you better have that
image now she'll tell her story next one
I don't care if I pronounce it right
it's close to Thanksgiving and I'm tired
public impeachment hearings start today
how we got here what happens next next
one Decca finally lenses Supreme Court
after Trump's year-long battle next one
Republican shrug off drawing evidence
stand with Trump against impeachment
next one here's the biggest news he
missed this weekend and then House
Intelligence Committee evidence of
Trump's extortion string so that one I
will give you the very first thing was
the biggest news you missed this weekend
which when I clicked it it was about
impeachment but two titles down
impeachment is in there so I think the
point remains if you want a nitpick
you're the dick
next one it's the same one Republicans
attempt to move impeachment inquiry away
from Trump next one White House broke
from the normal process handling Trump
Ukraine call witness said next one Trump
rails against Democrats impeachment
inquiry and growing body of evidence
keep in mind these are all being pumped
directly to my home screen every day I
did this test that you wouldn't have to
but here's the thing I want you to and I
want you to send your comments to me on
youtube or on Twitter I want everyone
who's wipe everything clean and try this
next one public impeachment earrings
will begin next week House says next one
key diplomat changes testimony miss quid
pro quo with Ukraine yeah you know I'm
not even gonna go through anymore here's
what I do want you understand we finally
added this up actually a brilliant
researcher reg into a spreadsheet to
look at the percentage of stories that
were coming in they were overwhelmingly
impeachment oriented and the only
conservative news source the only one
that was allowed at all as we saw on
Apple news was Fox News and keep in mind
throughout the entirety of these three
weeks we only received two stories from
Fox News I believe none of them were
political mind you the most political
one was about a guy stabbing a balloon
that was a Trump baby we can bring it up
here and you can determine for
yourselves if it's political there was
no balance in the sense of they were
talking about impeachment they were
talking about the Donald Trump and the
Ukraine scandal but there was no
bouncers are talking about hunter Biden
there was no talking about whatever is
been going on with Jill Biden there was
no talking about the flubs with any of
the Democratic presidential candidates
there's been no talking about the
inherent stories that were later on
Media bias or Jeffrey Epstein you know
James O'Keefe you'd think that would
none of those were up there and the only
conservative news source that was
allowed Fox News none of their political
stories were put into my feet
think of that for a second if you're
getting hundreds and hundreds of
articles listed pumped to the home
screen of your phone day in and day out
and none of them are coming from a
balanced news source and I bring this up
you know I don't want to fear monger I
think there's a real silver lining
Generation Z is more cat in spite of all
of this generation Z is more
conservative than Millennials or baby
boomers at this point in their
generation we see demographic shifts
taking place that we haven't seen before
there really is a bright future for
America if we do our work that being
said it really is pretty disturbing when
you add all of this up I mean you look
at Twitter banning political ads okay
that seems pretty balanced until you
realize that they allow media ads right
so ABC NBC CBS CNN they can all run ads
it's fine celebrities can run ads of
course publications can run ads just not
politicians you look at Google and
YouTube what we've been fighting over
there obviously been going on for a long
time Google and YouTube has specifically
changed their guidelines by and large
because of what we've done because of
what we've talked about in showcase as
for our search issues going on with
Tulsi Gabbard but we should a late night
show shouldn't be the ones to have to
catch them you see what's been happening
of course with Google manipulating
search results you know we talked about
3,000 dollars of Russian advertising
affecting the election TV any idea how
many votes can be swayed by Google and
YouTube alone think about that for a
second and last set two years ago we did
the Alexa video some people thought we
were faking it because we asked the
Alexa the Alexa in our house have less
sound like an old person the the Alexa's
asome who Muhammad was he was the
holiest of prophets peace be upon him
Jesus Christ it didn't know the answer
to it some people said that we were
faking because by the very next Monday
the algorithms that determined the
answers had changed and all of a sudden
was giving you an answer as to who Jesus
Christ was right sometimes all we think
that because by the time they asked him
a question three days later Amazon had
changed it I said because there's a
silver lining we can affect change we
just have to highlight where we see foul
play and make sure to make as much noise
about it as possible that's why I really
want to see
run this experiment again you have to
wipe everything clean so it's not going
that that excuse has been removed it's
not going based on algorithms and I
really am curious to see what you get
with your Apple news because now you
have you have Apple add into the mix so
we've already talked about Twitter we
already talked about YouTube Facebook
and I think this is what's really
disconcerting and why I want to talk
about this and hopefully give you some
time to digest this over the
Thanksgiving on Thanksgiving weekend as
more of a libertarian who believes in
limited government intervention we are
entering though into a new time a new
time here where you have several
companies that are more powerful than
most first world nations every think
about this for a second we were
concerned about the Patriot Act I mean
that libertarian liberals were really it
was more so an excuse for code pink to
protest where are they
lately or certainly after the Obama
years but we were all had a problem with
the Patriot Act libertarians because we
thought it was an invasion of privacy
and I still think that that's a problem
but I had ads popping up on my phone for
treatment for dogs dealing with lymphoma
and I didn't even search it on my phone
I was going based on some some
supplements that I was bringing in from
an Amazon app so I don't even know how
that happens think of how much just how
much Google Apple and YouTube obviously
goes with Google Facebook Twitter think
of how much they know about you and then
think of how silly it was for us to be
concerned as to whether someone was from
the NSA was listening to our
Thanksgiving stuffing tips with with paw
paw if you're if you're Elizabeth Warren
because that's apparently what the
Native Americans Redskins says oh we
Redskins Injuns that's what they say Paw
Paw congratulations Elizabeth Warren
you're the whitest person in the world I
know plenty of Native Americans they
never use the term paw paw but you just
think how concerned we used to be about
our privacy and now it's just something
that we wilfully give away for a little
bit of convenience you know something
else that really comes to mind here
people complain about corporate money
right in big oil and big pharma look at
the biggest companies in the world we've
talked about this out of the top five it
depends I think Amazon and an Apple
Store jockey for first position but you
have Amazon Apple Microsoft and alphabet
which is Google and YouTube those are in
the top five period across the
these are almost the most powerful
companies in the history of the world
and I mean this no one comes close at
all all agree they all come to the same
political persuasion and they all have
the ability to pinch the valve and close
that shut off the tap of information and
not just to you this is what I think it
bothers me so much when we when we
started doing this content on YouTube
and you know they used to call it new
media now it's just for four generations
II it's just media we thought well this
is great there aren't going to be the
same date keepers that you have on
television you're ABC NBC CBS we thought
now anyone can have a show and that was
true but now the gatekeepers are bigger
than any of those networks it's Google
Facebook Twitter Amazon Apple they are
the gatekeepers and they're more
powerful than ABC or NBC or CBS could
have been when people only had a few TV
sets and an engine came on in the middle
night when the TV was off that's what
happened after 11 o'clock the tv went
off and it was an Aboriginal duel that's
all it was these companies are more
powerful than any of them combined and
there's no oversight right now there's
no one keeping them accountable and
that's why two years ago we released a
video on the issues going on with Alexa
and by that Monday I think was released
on a Wednesday or Thursday by Monday it
changed we release it videos it relates
to Tulsi Gabbard what's been going on
with our search and then YouTube changes
search algorithms not all that long
after so I think it's most important
here yeah there's a lot there's a lot of
good going on in the country and I think
we're making some great strides but you
can't become complacent and this is as
much a request from you as it is
hopefully a tool to inform you if you
don't send in your own experiments your
own screengrabs upload them to youtube
upload them to Twitter you know upload
them as I'll try and share whatever I
can as long as we you know we do our due
diligence and it's valid if you guys
don't send that in and run these
experiments yourself like you did
yourselves like you did with Alexa which
is what changed policy then all of this
is for naught but for some reason people
haven't been focusing on what's going on
with Apple on your phone which everybody
has right now in in the modern world or
or an Android but it's effectively the
same thing it's something that most
people aren't talking about and I think
it's about
as important as an issue gets in 2019
going into 2020 going into an election
so I'm looking forward to see what you
send happy Thanksgiving I appreciate you
taking the time we weren't too many
squeaks Oh Betty's she didn't see she
just there you go she just ran around
the corner and she's killing something
it's dead